[Music]  hi my name is Gabrielle Union and my  weird fear is buying tampons in a  crowded drugstore so perhaps one day I  was having a heavy flow and I had to get  the super plus tampons and this is  information you just don't want out  there just in general and so I was in  the super plus tampon section and that's  precisely not the time you want to be  recognized maybe we're getting a table  perhaps or preferential treatment not  when you're buying su super plus tampons  because it just screams through the  world I have a heavy flow but right now  so I'll buy other crap that I don't need  like magazines to put on top of it  whatever's closest to the register Auto  Weekly I will stick them on top of my  tampons and it's also by fear that there  won't be a tag like a price tag on price  check for the super plus for the heavy  Flo gal here can we get that that's my  irrational fear  [Music]